I think I would describe it as both a
programming language and a powerful
computation engine I'm chief architect
at ianova we use Mathematica and the
Wolfram language in several different
ways primarily use it in our analytics
group to build models that help us make
decisions about as we develop new
products and also be able to offer
products to customers to help us decide
on whether or not what particular kind
of product we offer customer or four
examples for NS products on how much
money we might offer a customer we use
extensive analog modeling to do that and
we use Mathematica to as the engine for
for those models a lot of people that I
work with they're they're used to things
like oh I use SAS or I might use Python
or Ruby or C++ and when they encounter
Mathematica they don't understand that
it's actually doing all of those things
so instead of having to oh I'll do some
computation here in this other system
and then I'll write a program over here
in the other programming language that
with Mathematica you don't have to have
this split you can actually just write
all your logic right there in the
Wolfram language so the classes project
which was where we went from this old
system these were cut the models would
develop by analytics but then they had
to be coded by software engineering and
then deploy to production and that we
take several months with Colossus we
wanted to have a mechanism to have
analytics be able to make changes make
most of the changes deploy them to
production without actually involving
engineering at all so we looked at
several products and mathematica
actually won out I don't deal with small
sets of data all the data deal with is
thousands tens of thousands and hundreds
of thousands of data points and most
systems can't even begin to process
something even over a couple thousand
data points and mathematica it's capable
of doing it the biggest advantages are
speed of development both software
engineering and analytics can use
Mathematica sort of as a common language
to describe solutions to our problems
the ability to quickly prototype even
any random ID and be able to get it out
to production is also very critical the
third method is actually the third
advantage is Mathematica stata import
ability we have lots of different data
sources both third-party in-house
databases Excel various flat files from
other systems and with mathematical you
pull it in process it without having to
go back and forth 15 different systems
with traditional C++ in order to develop
a program it's going to take you know
several hundred lines of code to do
anything interesting with Mathematica I
can do something interesting in less
than five lines of code